millennials
were difficult but this younger
generation they're more activist which
when it's you know when it's like
climate change we love it but like when
you're like the intern and you're
sending an email to the CEO going I
don't think that you like it's like you
know there's other ways to do that
um
uh
it starts with empathy it starts with
empathy and we have to understand
it doesn't it's For Better or For Worse
the changing nature of what work has
become in our lives if you go back a
bunch of decades it used to be that you
got your sense of purpose from church
you got your sense of community from
bowling league you got you had you you
knew your neighbors you barbecued with
them on the weekends and work we were I
was loyal to work and work was loyal to
me at some point I'd get a gold watch
aside there's an entire generation that
when I talk about the gold watch they
have no idea what I'm talking about
right that's how much the world has
changed
um and and work was simply a place that
I made a living to pay my bills but
there was I still enjoyed my you know I
I it was still loyalty
over the course of time attendance
church attendance is down bowling clubs
don't exist anymore we don't talk to our
neighbors we become very insular and
what's happened is all of that pressure
is now being put on the office I now
expect my company to be the place where
I get my purpose the place I get my
friendships the place I get my community
at the place I get my social life now
we've also added the place you have to
agree with all of my politics
right that's a new one
and it's even now especially during
covet it's gone up even higher
especially for this young group
um where you also have to be my my
therapists my therapy I'm going to bring
all of my problems to work
and where we the idea of emotional
professionalism seems to have gone away
you know where you actually see people
sitting in meetings like this you're
like what's going on having a bad day
right that's emotionally unprofessional
right you can I want you to bring your
emotions to work I want you to bring
your whole self to work but but for the
same reason that we exercise emotional
professionalism in other aspects of Our
Lives we also do it at work
so one of the struggles of this young
generation is they are not equipped on
how to deal with stress
they're just less equipped than previous
generations for various reasons
including social media internet and all
that and you know parenting and all the
rest of it there's many reasons for it
but they're really not good at dealing
with stress they're really bad at
dealing with confrontation they're so
confrontation avoidant
that they would rather ghost someone
then break up with them after dating
them for six months
right that they would rather quit their
job than ask their boss for a raise
and usually in spectacular fashion like
you don't value me you don't pay me
enough you're like if you just asked I
would have given you a raise we love you
but they quit because they're just
afraid of the conversation
so they're very intimidated by
confrontation they're ill-equipped to
deal with stress
there's an emotional immaturity
emotional unprofessionalism
right and this it's not a good thing or
a bad thing it just is
and so us having empathy and
understanding that is important and so
it raises the question how are they
dealing with their stress not well and
so there's a new phenomenon that I'm
seeing happening in a lot of offices
where especially young people are
finding the one or two empathetic the
empaths on the team
and they're going to them with all of
their problems and it's not the
traditional I hate my boss I hate my job
venting about work is fine I have no
issue with that but it's I hate my mom I
don't know what I want to do with my
life when am I going to leave my house
what I you know my boyfriend's not
working out my girlfriend's not working
out like every problem in my life on
this one or two people at work and we've
had it happen on our team we had three
people quit
and I got a little team I got three
people who quit because they said they
were burnt out and I was like
you I know how much work you do what do
you mean you're burnt out so I'm like do
you have another job on the side
he burnt out
you know
what I discovered
is they were the impasse on the team and
everybody was calling them to unload
they were burnt out because they were
taking on everybody's stress and they
were exhausted they couldn't take it
anymore and they just quit
and when I talked about this publicly I
had a 23 year old come up to me in one
of the companies and said
I do that
and so we have to recognize they are
struggling
in a changing chaotic crazy world right
now where there's so much uncertainty in
this world like like the world is always
uncertain but my God it's War and the
countries added each other's throat and
there's Challenger and the global
warming and it's just insane these poor
kids and they have no outlet they don't
know how to deal with it so my my big
challenge my big uh it's a challenge for
all of us is how do we hold space for
them and the problem is is they don't
even recognize when we're doing the
right thing for them that's the hardest
part
a lot of anger
um but it's it's gonna the problem is
it's going to take a bit like we're in a
period of extreme flux
and it's it's not going to settle for a
little bit where it's going to be very
bumpy a very bumpy road for the next few
years there's no right answer
and you will be you will be um
you know no good deed will go unpunished
you know